[Music]
hello to everyone
miss coffee bean here finally letizia
has found some time to animate me
and give me my voice back i missed being
out here with you guys
today we are going to talk about peer
review in nlp
something that leticia has been busy
with during the last few days
and in this video we will be presenting
this
awesome paper by anna rogers and isabel
augenstein
it is a short paper accepted at mnlp
findings this year
it discusses how to improve peer review
a topic that could change the world
well could peer review really change the
world
yeah why not think about one of the main
chains of ideas research with new ideas
coming not only from academia but also
from industry
should be spread to others
one way to do this is through
publications
what ideas are valuable and impactful
enough to be
published is determined by peer review
where other scientists get to say how
much
they like the research and how much not
after publications the ideas can be
taken on by
others for improvement for further
spreading
or integration into super cool machine
learning applications right
but how to do the application part
properly
if the first part of the chain is flawed
because surprise surprise peer review
is broken if we want to know how to fix
it
we also want to know how it is broken so
it is time to look at
this paper even though the paper is
about the natural language processing
field
we think that the general message can be
useful for any kind of peer review
so let's see the paper really does not
mess around
and starts abruptly with harsh claims
like
peer review does not guarantee quality
control
ouch but no matter how much this
sentence hurts we cannot but
agree to what they argue peer review
is meant to guarantee that what is
written in the paper
is correct and high quality but this
is an impossible task because the papers
are not
reproducible especially when thinking
about the
poor reviewers with limited time and
unpaid review work then the others say
that
peer review fails to detect impactful
papers again very harsh but
quite true important for paper impact
is often not only the science itself but
other factors like
the topic the promotion on for example
the social media
or how easy it is to take an idea and
build on it further look at for example
bird or transformers okay
so surprise surprise peer review is hard
and ill defined
so the authors ask what could peer
review
realistically do well
it could filter out obvious flaws and
turn the spotlight on to quality
right but the problem is
that we are not doing that instead we
are selecting or
trying to select the best x percent
of the papers and accept them
what could possibly go wrong here by ah
yes we do not know where and how to draw
the line
the idea that miss coffee being
appreciated the most
out of this paper is represented in this
figure
reviewing is like comparing apples with
oranges
different papers have different
strengths
one has better methodology the other one
has better evaluation
or should we select the idea but not so
much its implementation
or what should we focus actually on i
don't know how to judge this i'm not
gonna actually
my special so while miss coffee bean is
having a mental breakdown
i can tell you that the other thing that
i liked most about this paper
is the idea that reviewers choose
different ways of coping with
this impossible task that is required
from them
so miss coffee bean now that you
recovered from your breakdown
what are the coping mechanisms ah
writing style it is hard to resist the
temptation to
think that if there are language errors
in the paper
the science is bad too but this thinking
is so
wrong non-native english speakers can
produce
awesome science too well the next way to
cope with the impossible reviewing task
is to look at only
one table in the paper you know the one
containing the result
if the proposed contribution is not the
best there
we reject we want only state of the art
right
you know but this ignores many things
like efficiency
interpretability all the other goodies
beyond a high score
in the evaluation metrics niche topics
like you know
everything that is not transformer or is
not
i cite the paper scientifically sexy
is so hard to publish especially in
natural language processing
it is easy to publish work on english
language but it is hard on
others as if findings on other languages
are not as generalizable as the findings
on english
to this wall of shame the authors
further add the problem
widespread in the whole machine learning
area
like already famous work where
researchers publish
already on archive so the anonymous peer
review is not so anonymous in the end
also big labs which invest a lot of work
into public relations are famous and
they get even more
famous in my observation the big labs
are even more recognizable
in review just by you know compute
resources or even plotting styles
so let's move on to the next coping
mechanism
we sometimes tend to shame two simple
solutions because simple means
it is easier right nope it's not
over complication is easier than
simplicity
another way of coping is through
spotlighting mainstream approaches like
deep learning but no deep learning is
not the answer to everything
and other methods have their merit too
and especially in the big data
requirements of deep learning it is
quite unintuitive why we do not
appreciate
resource papers so much so okay we're
almost at the end of the wall
of shame novel approaches are too
often rejected this sounds absurd
yes and the authors explain it through
the human way of saying
no to new stuff because it is hard to
comprehend especially at first
and the last and i think by far the
worst entry
of the wall of shame are substitute
questions that reviewers tend to ask
in the impossible situations of
assessing
quality if i did this study would i have
made
the same choices and in our opinion this
is the
worst coping mechanism because it is the
most subjective one and has to do
a lot with the different backgrounds and
personal ways of thinking of reviewers
i mean the other coping mechanisms are
at least expected and easy to counter
but this last point about the substitute
questions is as varied as there are
reviewers
for example if you write a paper and
test your model
on data set x and data set y the
reviewer says
or asks but why did you not test on data
set
z the reviewer might actually mean
if i did this study i would have tested
on z
and the problem with this question is
that it is hard to say if the reason for
having data set z
is really scientifical or just you know
personal
so anyway while looking at this wall of
shame one might come
up with the idea just to abolish peer
review
but we remind about what we discussed at
the beginning of this video where we
need to
have a filter for publications for
non-experts so they know what's quality
and what's not
so what to do the authors of the paper
propose that reviewer work
should be more valued and the working
hours taken
into account by employers review work
should really not be done by overworked
people
in their spare time and then they
propose some ways to reduce the
uncertainty that comes with the poorer
task definition of reviewing
for example more organization energy
should be invested into reviewer
matching for
assigning competent reviewers for each
research topic then the review task
should be more fine-grained to capture
the diversity of papers and also the
review forms
should be able to capture this
announcing the conference or journal
priorities before
submission and reviewers giving not an
overall score but
specific scores that are weighted
differently
depending on these editorial priorities
should
also improve the definition of the task
of peer review
and the reviewers faced with a
well-defined task would be
then relying less on coping mechanisms
okay so when do we do this many others
had the ideas presented in this paper
and what i really appreciate most is
that the authors managed to remind here
by
everybody again about the peer review
problems
so maybe this wake up call will finally
have some effect
miss coffee bean wanted to spread the
word further with this video
if you want to help too share this video
with anybody
interested or share the paper you can
find the link to the paper in the
description below
see you next time okay bye